let's allow them some time to join us
again I'm passing on the
rights to you you should be able to
present Imran please check
not yet
sorry
not able to share in West India can you
please
sure
please try now
hello everyone greetings to all joining
us from various parts of the world both
in the evening and morning
I'm delighted to extend a warm welcome
to you for the fourth online convocation
ceremony brought to you by Central in
collaboration with caltex ctm
my name is mohini single and I serve as
a program manager at simply learn
responsible for ensuring the success of
Learners pursuing courses with dialectic
cdme
I would like to begin by extending my
heartfelt congratulations to all the
graduates your accomplishment is a
remarkable feat that many perceive to be
nearly impossible
I can sense the enthusiasm in the air
which is solely devoted to you your
family friends professors the management
at caltex ctme and simply learn and
every individual attending this even
today are incredibly proud of you I'm
confident that many of you are excited
about the future and simultaneously feel
a great sense of relief that all the
hard work and challenges are now behind
you
it's time to take a step back relax and
reveal in this momentous occasion
allow me to take a moment to reflect in
the journey that led you to this
momentous achievement
over the past six to eight months you
dedicated your weekends to attend eight
hours of Life sessions you invested
hundreds of us in learning through live
virtual classes online self-learning
videos I'm completing around 20 plus
assessments and projects
by applying the knowledge and skills
required you completed the Capstone
project leading to the moment of clerk
I must say that the accomplishment
demanded immense commitment and passion
from you
your unwavering determination along with
the support of your loved ones did not
go unnoticed therefore I would like to
take this opportunity to applaud and
appreciate each and every one of you
I also express my gratitude to your
family and friends for their unwavering
support which contributed to your
success story
moving on to the chief Kasper today I am
thrilled to announce our first guest of
honor Dr Rick Kepner
Rick currency serves as an executive
director at caltic Institute of
Technology and brings with him over 40
years of invaluable experience in system
development organizational management
and education
he is a PhD in applied Dynamics system
control from UCL
Dr Hepner provides professional
development programs for technology
driven organizations and individuals
he has helped guide technology adoption
in over 30 Aerospace communication
electronics and Health Sciences
Dr Hepner is credited with over 200
presentations and publication and is
active in several professional Society
Dr Hypno we would request you to share
your thoughts for our graduates today
great thank you mohini and welcome and
congratulations to all of the graduates
here this is a very special day
so let me add my congratulations to all
the graduates successfully completing
all the various programs today
your achievements are proof of your
unwavering dedication
your skills and the knowledge that
you've gained will undoubtedly Propel
your careers forward
this convocation marks the start of a
journey that I hope will be filled with
success fulfillment and boundless
opportunities
best of what uh wishes to your future
endeavors and please keep us posted on
all your progress I hope this uh this is
a first step in your careers and an
opportunity for you to uh to improve
your situation
congratulations
thank you Dr Hector for inspiring words
I'm delighted to welcome our second
guest of corner for today Mr Mike Ash
he's a program director of caltex ctme
Mike is extremely passionate about the
new age Technologies and how the impact
of it would make the society and the
world we live in a better place
he's a Harvard Business School Alvin act
and has also been associated with many
Fortune hundred companies in formulating
competitive strategies guiding them to
industryship related to digitization and
globalization and consumer preference
thanks to micro bracing this ceremony
today our graduates would like to hear
from you
absolutely thank you it's my profound
honor to be here with all of you today
I've I've spoken with many of you over
the past several months but I'm here not
just as an administrator in caltech's
division for engineering and applied
science but really as an admirer of your
dedication the perseverance that you
bring to kind of this immense effort
um in to have these comprehensive
technology-centric boot camp programs
which we'd love uh teaming with simply
learn to create for you today we're
Gathering not just to Mark the end of of
your Learning Journey your initial
Learning Journey I hope you're always a
lifelong learner we want to celebrate
the beginning of kind of a new chapter
that's equipped with you know you have
new skills you have new knowledge and
insights and the experiences that you've
accumulated over the past
um half year or so in the program
but each one of you is dedicated
um a commitment to personal growth and
the people that I spoke to and coach on
what kind of programs are available to
them who often talk about the intensity
of of these programs and and how to make
way uh to where you're going to be
really successful and you've all spent
countless hours in in mastering uh new
tools algorithms techniques problem
solving methods
code building applications and trying
just new things whether you are already
familiar with technology or you were
just beginning
the projects that you worked on the
Capstone that you recently completed is
really a testament to your tenacity that
you've got an ability to apply what
you've learned and and do so much more
uh we hope to see that you're going to
solve real world problems uh the things
that you've gone through are not easy uh
these are kind of challenging tasks and
you Rose to those challenges
so really proving that you know your
determination is what is really going to
make you successful in your career so
today let us
not just celebrate your graduation but
also a transformation from learning new
technologies as you step into the future
and really create positive impact in our
world thank you everybody I'm excited to
hear from you
thank you Mr Mike now I'd like to
introduce you the sponsor for today our
chief marketing officer Dr will be Lim
will is a result driven marketing
executive with extensive International
experience and proven track record in
managing 100 million dollar plus Global
Marketing budgets he has extensive
experience in scaling businesses and
taking them to the next level
he has worked in marketing and digital
leadership roles with organizations like
Microsoft helvet beggar and Expedia
among others Dr Lim is a PhD in
operations research and industrial
engineering and also holds a masters in
aerospace engineering from the
University of Texas at Austin
he currently resides with wife and two
daughters in Seattle and has been a
major influence in making caltex CDMA
programs at Center learn a successful
one well we are thrilled to have you
join us today and I invite you to share
a few words with the congratulence
thank you
um so to my fellow Learners I like to
extend my deep and how um congrats to
you on this achievement you have a big
group of us both Caltech and simply
learned cheering young today as you
receive your recognition and certificate
and we are so honored to be part of this
special day
I applaud you for your dedications it's
not easy to juggle among personal
commitment work and study all at once
take a moment and Savor your reward and
celebrate with your loved ones and
friends and please do me a favor if you
want if you will be celebrating your
achievement on social media please
remember to tag caltac and simply learn
just doing my job as a part of achieve
marketing over so far for simply learned
so sorry for that
um
so I have to actually take a peek of uh
the profile of this group of uh Learners
right so we have a total of 600 Learners
all together right and if there's
actually one word I can summarize uh
this group of Learners it is diversity
right and not only that this group is
Diversified but also highly educated and
experienced and so please make sure that
you continue to stay in touch with your
and network with your fellow Learners
right this is actually not only a
learning opportunity but also
opportunity for you to Network and and
grow your um you know exposure to uh to
other industry as well
um you may not have realized but you now
belong to an elite community of Learners
who have completed a technically events
and focus intense
Pro post sorry post uh postgraduate
program uh at caltac based on what I
have come to know and people who
successfully complete these programs
always demonstrate the characteristics
of curiosity passion Independence
self-confidence and perseverance you
ought to be proud of yourself for
mastering all these great qualities
as a member of this continuous uh High
Learning Community I'm hopeful that you
will become an advocator and an
ambassador for it finally I hope that
your new learn skill will unlock even
more doors to the success you very well
deserve congratulations again
so uh as I mentioned earlier right in
terms of diversity and all that he is
actually one slide which actually
demonstrate that right um you know 600
Learners coming from many different
Industries and with uh you know
different years of experiences and as
you can see that it's actually biased
towards the uh um uh you know very
experienced folks and professionals
that's great thank you will for your
valuable insights and message
now it's a moment of Celebration and
recognition for all those who have
successfully completed their
postgraduate program with us
to give an overview of the numbers of
qualified Learners we would like to
provide a brief summary
170 Learners from 11 cohorts have
qualified in devops an impressive 358
Learners from 17 cohorts have qualified
in cloud computing
63 Learners from pipe to Whatsapp
qualified in full stack web development
eight Learners graduated from data
science and five from Ai and machine
learning program each having one bought
let's now proceed to honor and
congratulate all our graduates
as we move forward with the recognition
of our graduates I would like to express
my sincere apologies in advance for any
mispronunciation of needs
if we have accidentally missed out on
any names please do not worry
it is not intentional and we welcome you
to reach out to us and we will make sure
to accommodate you in the next one
without further Ado let's begin with the
postgraduate program in Cloud engraving
graduates
in this category we have Suresh ankur
darshan Shankar Pavan pradeep ritesh
Tushar subrada and Girish
congratulations to all of you
next we have the moon
Supriya akanksha vishnumita
congratulations to all of you
congratulations to our YouTubers
next up we have Tushar Yusuf Andy
Asma chitra Vidya Sagar and Amit
congratulations to all of you
deependra Prabhu edwell Catherine
srinivasan jigar rishin Amit and chinna
congratulations to all of you
next we have Sajid while Rohit nitin
suparna
[Music]
congratulations to all of you
bachina moshmita and Sunni
congratulations to all of you next we
have abhimya abhiji
Abhishek Abhishek
congratulations to all of you
dance
nezo
Olive
congratulations to all the achievers
Praveen Priti Suman raghavendra Rahul
Rajesh Raju ramkumar Rashmi Richa
samarendra Robert Rohan ramaldo rupali
Sai Karan Tara Salim Salman and SRI
ragamindra congratulations to Olympia
Shreya
shooting Siva
Mika Sonia andrajit congratulations to
all of you
Deva
Lakshmi
Blue bikinis and srinivas
congratulations to all of you
vipin
vishwas
Supriya Haroon
Muhammad Marini and adarsh
congratulations to all of you
Manish Prasad Usman
prabhakar nil Akila
is
congratulations to all of you
next we have giant Anand shares Murtaza
sanjee Kumar ramanpreet Avinash vinod
chandrashekhar Ajit aparna di pandar
abhinya
Amin andisha Amit charu
congratulations to all of you
even deepankar Abdel feroz even
him
and Balaji congratulations to all the
achievers up next we have
nalini nikhil Ali pradeep Prashant Priya
Priyanka puneet Raji Rajesh rivan Jim
bebuff surender Mustafa shravan
sujit shamik and Samantha
congratulations to all of you
next we have subanna
karnal telling Rohit Vidya Vidya vimal
Sunita yogendra sandhi Aji Muhammad
firdaus
Narendra parish and sairam
congratulations to all of you
Miriam nimish nitish Kumar Rahat Rohit
and sanjana
congratulations to all of you now before
we move forward I would like to call it
well to the panelists to share his
journey with all of us today
can you please move into the panelist
give me a minute
um
hello everybody you have now a panelist
please unmute yourself and switch on
your video while you speak
hello hello
good morning good morning how are you
I'm fine good afternoon good evening
from around the world
ladies and gentlemen
it is my absolute pleasure to read
before you today as we celebrate the
achievement of our postgraduate program
with caltex ctm in the field of cloud
computing
as a cloud computing associate
I have not only acquired technical
Knowledge and Skills but I've also
joined a host of Pioneer in the field
that continually and relentlessly pushes
the boundaries of what is possible
dedication hard work and countless hours
are spent mastering complex concepts are
shaped me in the field
in a provisional ready to tackle the
challenges of an Ever advancing digital
landscape
and to my learned colleagues and not
only obtain a comprehensive
understanding of cloud computing but
have also cultivated a mindset of
continuous learning and adaptation
yet as we celebrate the achievement of
our graduation today
it is important to remember that
knowledge is not an endpoint but rather
the beginning of a lifelong journey
ladies and gentlemen permit me to share
a quote with you from one of my favorite
authors Napoleon Hill
it is it is literally true that you can
succeed best and quick quickest by
helping others to succeed
with this quote I would like to express
my deepest gratitude to The Faculty
members at simple and boot camp
for the time spent supporting me and my
colleagues on many occasions
thank you very much for the course I
enjoyed every minute of your lectures as
well as your exemplary moment of candid
class con discussions
in conclusion may I offer my best
regards to your laptops
I sincerely hope they are fully
recovered
thank you
that's greeted Bill thank you for your
kind word it was great to have you here
and congratulations on completing your
program with us thank you thank you
let's move on to the next
week quickly check just a minute
I'll take it off from here Imran let's
go to the next uh set of learners
Karthik
yasher Darko
John guy saket Anil lajan
congratulations
many many congratulations to each one of
you
congratulations on your achievements
Melvin Mahesh
antariksha anthon Satish congratulations
Adrian Alexander Amit Antonio anurag
Arnold Ashish Avinash Balaji Benjamin
blessing
check them
Deepak tiwari Miguel Edward
Evia
family many many congratulations on your
achievement
John Joshua Mamu Yogi Manan Manoj Nadia
Naga vimala gaurav Natasha
rajendra Brian
sayam
shashikant Pandit many many
congratulations
Shivam
SRI subhashini Shivam sushil Karthik
Adrian Vivek William
Macaulay Richard Alexander J theavi
Lucas Anton
Clement many many congratulations on
your achievement
Vishal
Derek
Tony
Loretta talumoy agrita
um
ravichandra Rohit
ayappa Danny Kevin
Nick congratulations
shubham
as Akash Ali divine
[Music]
prakash Matthew
rajat she
Vivek
congratulations on your graduation
Darwin Katie Bikram Seema rajveer Sharad
himanshu Akshay prabhuram srikant saurav
Neha
many many congratulations
Ajay
honey
Albert Ashish Karthik
Jared constantina Laura congratulations
once again
Hayden Libya Manali
susha Satish
shiv Shankar Singh prasanna
priyadarshini Irma aparna Sachin
samarth shrijeet Merlin and Ajay many
many congratulations once again on your
graduation
before we move ahead a couple of
Learners from devops program wanted to
share their Learning Journey with us
can you please have rakshit move to the
panelist
hello rakshit you are a panelist now
request you to unmute yourself and
switch on your video while you speak
yes hello Hall uh thank you for
providing this opportunity to speak
today uh my experience with the first
graduates have been great fun has been
great uh we were taught by emailing an
audience
[Music]
practical
trainer they had experience working in
devops especially I want to thank
trainers Ashford and
acceptance we did a lot of bands on in
the class also they gave us a lot of
projects now I'm able to do a lot of
projects by myself
even the labs provided basically there
was to create uh
uh with the knowledge I have expired in
this devops certification I am
continuing to learn more and more than
the MFS are applying for new jobs now
yeah thank you for all the knowledge
provided yeah thank you
for sharing your experience with us we
are glad that this program helped you
with your up stealing uh next up we have
Darko
can we please move him to the panelist
so that he can share his experience with
us
good morning you are now in the
panelists please unmute yourself and
switch on your video Promise Me
uh hello everybody uh I hope you can
hear me well uh good evening to my
Indian fellows good day to my European
and good morning to my U.S colleagues
uh first of all thank thank you very
much to Simply learn for uh having a
great great platform where we
learn
uh where we had show us the real life
cases that we can learn we had a
head-ons on the projects that we can
actually apply in real life
a platform that has also a self-learning
approach for others who need this part
of the uh this part of the learning
processes thanks to the Caltech to
Bringing uh their knowledge also to this
and making this uh
education information even better
uh my my experience is really great I'm
absolutely uh
telling everybody that they should
probably try this I'm already working
and I wanted to move from a virtual
software to kind of hybrid the
uh environments that we are starting to
use in my company that's actually close
to Caltech
and this helped me a lot and I I'm
hoping I'm gonna bring my company uh
great uh and this part of the technology
uh I want to thank to Simply learn to
give me a little bit of a break and help
when uh I was close to finish my
Capstone project and something happened
with my family member
a very bad news came so I was under the
shock I was close to finish my project
but I just couldn't and so they allowed
me to postpone my project and that I
could do it like two months later and
this helped me a lot to finish so I want
to thank them again for their great
support
and
probably gonna come back at some point
or something colleagues
thank you darcu for sharing your
experience with us we will now move to
the postgraduate program in full stack
web development
Q can be moved to the list of learners
so first of all Muhammad was
Stephen Moses Ashish Peter many many
congratulations
Brian
Brian Daniel Damian Deepak Greg Hassan
Xavier Judith
Ken
milind
upe Junaid
ayushi
many many congratulations
Ryan
Shanta sheetal Sue
Vishnu
Wayne
engineer Avida Rupal Asha
Amita many many congratulations
sort of
Stephen
soon
Akash many many congratulations everyone
we now move on to the postgraduate
program in data science
and here we have graduates Mr trines
congratulations
many many congratulations on your
achievement
moving on to the postgraduate program in
Ai and machine learning we have
brahmarshi Dennis
many many congratulations on your
achievement and a huge applaud to all
the Learners who have completed their
graduation
my colleague mohini is back and she will
take up the rewards and recognition
section from here on thank you mohini
thank you
we understand that in Walking on this
journey this is not easy and we
acknowledge all of you out of achieves
however there are some Learners who have
gone above and beyond it is playing a
competitive spirit
to recognize the outstanding efforts we
have arranged two sets of award for the
evening
the first category is the scholar award
which is presented to the top two
performance in each category
based on the completion of Life classes
projects and assessments as well as
their cumulated skills first I would
like to call out the scholars for
postgraduate program in cloud computing
and the winners are Gigi Jacob who
completed the program till 88.5
and so they should completed the program
with 87.6 congratulations to both of you
the next category belongs to
postgraduate programs in DeVos in this
category the winners are Sushi who
completed the program in 89.7 and maybe
who completed the program in 86.49
congratulations to both of you before we
move forward I would request TV
to move to the panelist so that she can
help share her journey with us
let's give it a moment or so he is
joining us
in the meantime let's move forward
the next categy belongs to both graduate
programs in full start web development
and the Vanessa Ryan who completed the
program with 91.08 and tagara who
completed the program at 9.15
congratulations to both of you
next up we have post project programming
data science and the winners are
abhilash who completed the program with
80.98 and vinod Kumar who completed the
program in 79.27
congratulations to both of you
last but not least we have postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning
who completed the program in 82.4
percent
who completed the program with 78.5
congratulations to both of you
now before we move forward let me call
approva to the panelists so that she can
share her journey with us
wow
hi everyone sorry
um I'm not sure if I'm visible or not
yes you are yeah
perfect so hi everyone this is Anna and
um I was working as a full start
developer and I made a choice to move to
machine learning and uh simply learn
skytech program was one of the few
courses I came across and it looked you
know at that point good enough to
complete it to to kind of meet all my
requirements this was my first
experience as an online celebration
program which went on for you know this
duration six months and honestly a lot
have happened during this I've gotten
married I've moved to UK and a lot of
changes have happened in my life during
this program and I'm honestly done
applying this pre-learning team because
they helped me out a lot from helping me
meet uh deadlines to looking away when I
couldn't attend all the classes and it
was it was an interesting experience and
the simply learning team really really
made it very easy and as Mike mentioned
in the beginning that the number of
topics which we covered during these
past six months they were overwhelming
at times
and a lot of information and at times it
felt as if I wasn't doing justice to all
the material which has been provided to
us and all the topics which has been
discussed with us but uh I think the
clue was just to hang in there and take
us back as much as you can and now that
I'm actually in the field of machine
learning and I'm working on it I
realized that I can always go back to
those classes and just you know review
them and uh sort of do a quick revision
of what we learned and it really really
helps so I'm really glad with the course
material which you guys shared with us
I'm really really thankful for the
teachers who were there involved in this
process and this and and the folks who
helped us out in the background so thank
you it was an excellent experience and
it's something I I wish everyone should
experience once in a while uh once in
their life too uh just stay up to date
on this field
thank you again
thank you football thanks it's a
privilege to be a part of your journey
as well so thank you so very much and
congratulations once again
foreign
to the panelists so that she can share
her journey with us
can we please
move her to the panelist
also Brahma Shay I see you are all your
panelists can you please unmute yourself
and switch on the camera as you speak
yes good evening to Dieter sir
and the technical team the whole simple
learn team and all my fellow fellow
mates from all over the world I am
feeling very great to be the part of
this event organized by simply learn Tim
today and uh
in my journey it's like I am new to this
field and uh the learning provided by
simple and faculty it's simply superb I
have learned lot of new things in past
six months and still learning through
various uh OSL modules live classes
recorded classes and ebooks it is uh
like it is providing me a new
a new way of thinking towards a
technology it's a completely new
technology for everyone for me also and
I am trying to extract maximum maximum
of it through all these uh through all
these resources and I am very very
thankful for this uh for this uh
opportunity provided by the simply land
to me thanks a lot for this thank you
thank you Brahma Shri thank you for your
kind words and congratulations once
again thank you thank you so much
moving on to the second set of awards
for the evening we will recognize
Learners who are able to quickly the
program end to end in this shortest
Edition
we call them the speedrunners from
postgraduate program in cloud computing
we have Abdul who completed the program
in hundred days and Supriya who
completed the program in 101.
congratulations to both of you
next up the half course graduate program
in devops and the winners are shusha who
completed the program in 134 days and
rucha who completed the program in 136
days congratulations to both of you
up next we have postgraduate program in
full stack web development and the
winners are aporva Rao who completed the
program in 265 days and abeda who
completed the program in 272 days
congratulations to both of you
next we have postgraduate program in
data science the winners are Creations
who completed the program in 132 days
and saranya who completed the program in
166 days congratulations to both
before we move forward let's call
saranya to the Palace so that she can
share her experience with all of us
today
in the meantime
we can okay yeah
oh hi everyone uh thank you so much for
uh for giving me this opportunity uh to
share my experience about this uh data
science program uh first of all I would
like to thank all the faculties who
trained us uh in this data science
course especially uh shubham Pandey sir
um who trained Us in machine learning so
his uh training his uh classes were very
engaging and for a person like me who
had zero knowledge on machine learning
he made it very easier and uh he uh very
uh in a simplified form he taught uh end
to end about machine learning so um and
also uh I should say talk about the
course materials
uh in the PDF format it would be in the
videos it could be the recorded sessions
um enough number of data sets to
practice and all these are really
helpful and lifelong access to the
recorded sessions uh means a lot uh
whenever we whenever uh we can always go
back and we can refer to all the course
materials
um and most importantly uh uh the unique
thing about this program is uh
certificates under every topic so that
is even more uh interesting and we can
add each and every certificate to our
LinkedIn profile which will definitely
have a huge impact in our job pursue in
data science in data science uh career
for the person like me who wants to I'm
a software engineer so who wants to
switch from
uh wants to switch to data data science
field and uh and also thank you Caltech
uh a certificate coming from Caltech is
uh really uh an added uh uh big thing
and it is uh like it definitely it will
have a huge impact on our job Pursuit uh
in data science field
and also last but not the least thank
you simply learn team uh without your
help and guidance uh this wouldn't have
been a a smooth Journey right from the
enrollment process uh till today it is
uh wonderful and enriching experience
and uh thank you all once again uh for
this wonderful Journey thank you
thanks so much for sharing the kind
words we are privileged to be a part of
The Learning Journey thank you so much
moving on to the next category we have
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning
who completed the program in 112 days
and Dennis who completed the program in
148 days
let's give a huge roundabout Applause to
all the winners in all the categories
now I would like to introduce you to the
team's responsible for ensuring that you
have optimal learning experience the
idea behind this is to put a piece to
the names you have heard and interacted
within the past year
first I'd like to introduce our faculty
team
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank our faculty for supporting us
throughout the program they have been
the major pillars of your experience and
would like to call out each faculty and
thank them on your behalf
thank you to all of you
next up we have Raji Prashant
akashindra and swaminathan thank you to
all of you
sujada rajendra Puja Ashu Sebastian and
prakash thank you to all of you
thank you to all of you
now I would like to call out a few of
our faculty to speak their Journey with
us first up we have sonal middle can we
please move her to the panelist
hey sonal you have the panelist access I
request you to switch on your camera and
unmute yourself as you speak
hey hi can you hear me yes I can pay
just fine
okay
hey everybody very very good evening
I hope you all are able to hear me yes
you simply learned for inviting me here
to speak
many many congratulations to each one of
you for completion of this Caltech ctme
program
it's a proud moment
and you all have worked hard together to
earn the certification especially when
we all had these long hours of trainings
with me you had quizzes assessments
Capstone projects that were involved
now you are entering into this exciting
field in the world which is devops
right in indeed devops is the worst
trending software development approach
right now
right which is having various technical
as well as business benefits over the
last decade changing business models and
increased competition have led to
skyrocketing interest in devops you will
all agree with me on that
companies which are large small or old
or very new companies we are seeing a
short success when they're adopting with
devops tools methodologies and processes
well you know that I can continue
speaking about devops it is never
sufficient well I'll move on uh of
course devops will certainly be a
catalyst in advancing your professional
career uh and what uh you know it's
starting a journey with simply learn uh
add with Caltech ctme program in
collaboration with simple learn is
amazing great job everyone
now to talk about simply learn also
plays an important role and an exciting
role in my career too being a faculty
member at Caltech PG program it's a
learning process every day for me
and as a trainer I wish you all to
embark on your own Journey with the
devops tools devops processes go out in
this world and make a difference in your
unique way
just like life never stops teaching us
lessons every day similarly devops is a
never-ending learning process be open
and receptive to keep learning because
if any point of time you feel that you
have learned everything you will that's
that's a point when you think okay I
know every
they know that's when you need to get
into and learn more new things in devops
or cloud computing or anywhere right
it's always said as you live you learn
and as you learn you'll every day so I
wish you all the very best much success
and make an impact in everybody's life
congratulations once again thank you so
much everyone
thank you Mom thank you so much for your
kind words and you've always been an
inspiration thank you so much
to share her experience her journey with
all of this today can we please move her
to the panelist
so gitika I see you do have the access I
request you to unmute yourself and
switch on the video as we speak
hi everybody
warm wishes and it is a pleasure to come
together with simply learn and Learners
to celebrate the completion and success
of this challenging Journey that we all
wanted to together I would like to thank
sampleon for inviting me here to speak
I'm honored to be here many
congratulations to each one of you for
this momentous achievement you and your
families should be proud of what you
have accomplished you are entering into
one of the most exciting fields that
exist in the world today
cloud computing as we all know has been
addressed as the champion of the
information age
indeed it is hard to find a modern
company that does not store and access
data in the cloud so at the helm of its
revolutionary impact is a realization
that cloud computing is the ultimate
democratizing force it has facilitated a
seismic shift in terms of Business
Development by bringing vast Computing
resources to even the smallest of
businesses the cloud has caused a
massive shift in the availability of
computing power by enabling
entrepreneurs to easily set themselves
up with infrastructure and applications
upon which to run their Enterprises
cloud computing can be a major career
revolutionizing Catalyst and such a
journey is very well deserved to be
taken through this Caltech cdme program
in collaboration with simply learn
simply learn has made a big difference
in my life as well being a faculty
member of the Caltech PG program has
allowed me to join a dynamic industry
and to work for one of the best Ed tech
companies in the world I would also like
to thank my family here for all their
unconditional support because of which
this could be possible at the very first
place and in the spirit of Celebration I
want to wish all the Learners an
impactful cloud computing Journey a
special thanks from the bottom of my
heart to my simply learned team
especially or people who spotted me out
to name my team like I would say amen
and everybody who have actually believed
in me trusted in me always always
accepted my request thank you so very
much I have I'm really sure also thank
you all thank you once again wishing you
a very very very impactful journey ahead
thank you
thank you Mom it was an absolute
pleasure to be with you and have been
have you with simple learn thank you so
much okay thank you
last but not the leads I would like to
welcome
ayushrathi to the panelists to share his
journey with us
am I Audible
yes you are thank you
so hi everybody I am ayush rathi and I
am a cloud evangelist as well as faculty
for the post graduation program and
cloud computing uh where you all went
through the comprehensive curriculum
within industry aligned learning path
which is definitely going to be a game
changer for all of you in your journey
first of all one wishes it's a pleasure
to come here to celebrate the success of
the great journey that we have all
unfolded and learned together and
discovered a lot of things around cloud
so congratulations to all of you on this
significant accomplishment definitely
it's a proud proud moment for all of you
and your families as you're reaching
this major milestone
it's an honor to be associated with such
a pride University Caltech along with
simply learn where I have had a
wonderful experience delivering the
overall program where it was a mix of
self-paced videos live Hands-On sessions
a lot of cases studies Capstone
I hope you all had exciting time with us
the cloud computing program can be a
major career transforming agitator for
you all and it would definitely help you
in your career I guess there would be no
company today that does not want to
leverage cloud
so plethora of opportunity in this space
once again I would like to wish all of
our graduates a sincere congratulations
your determination has been ospiring so
here's wishing you all a journey onwards
upwards and skywards and thank you
Caltech and simply learn for the
opportunity and all the teams uh behind
the scene LSM content product for making
this a go-to and a great program
thank you
thank you ayush thank you for your kind
words and it was a pleasure to be with
you have you in the sessions taking you
through all the journey for the Learners
thank you so very much and thank you to
each and every faculty member that we
have
now I will move on to thank our Master
Class instructors part of the garlic
family facilitating us with different
interesting topics every month
thank you Patrick Dr John Matthew Eugene
Dave Chris and Dr D thank you very much
next up I would like to extend my hands
to the learner success team this team is
accountable conducting sessions and
addressing support requests submitted by
Learners with whom many individuals may
have direct or indirect interactions
thank you to all of you
next up we have Ashwini Asha Anamika and
Puja thank you to all of you
next up we have the faculty and the
alignment team responsible to carefully
select and provide us with the finest
trainers
[Music]
thank you to all of you
moving on I would like to introduce the
product team this team comprises the
real architects of the program and its
structure
this team serves as a link between
simpler and caltex ctme
and our driving posts behind the program
we have Abhishek abhinav Mohan Mayan Ann
Arna and shovel thank you to all of you
next up we have the product the content
game this team is responsible for the
curriculum that is covered in the form
of life virtual classes self-learning
videos lab demos and assessments
thank you
last but not least thanks our leadership
team who regulates the direction of all
programs and oversee the learner's
success team
a big shout out to Subhash nichandran
madhurima Kosh Siddharth chakravarti
nagendra and myself mohin
thank you to all of you
let us express our appreciation and give
a round of applause to these team for
their hard work dedication
addition to the aluminati who imparted
their knowledge we appreciate all the
individuals who have provided reviews
for our program on social media
it's immensely satisfying and thrilling
to see feedback posted on various
platforms as a testament of our program
we have also taken the criticism
seriously worked diligently to address
problems and strive to offer a better
learning experience
with that we conclude the fourth edition
of our online convocation for post
programs in collaboration with Cindy
learn and caltex
let's just do all the batteries for
their future endeavors and strongly
believe that having aspirations is the
first step towards success you all
arrived here with dreams and aspirations
and we are now confident that many of
you will excel in various fields of your
careers we would like to leave you with
one final thought tip
you are for the caltex CME simply
others will look to yourself as a
Guiding Light towards their own
accomplishment
we encourage you to stay at the
community by posting topics for future
learners
and keeping this updated on your
achievements
please tag us on social media so that we
can celebrate with you and happy the way
for you to learn
once again we extend our heartfelt
gratitude to choosingly learn as your
partner for upskilling
good night good day and good luck
everyone
thank you everyone for taking out time
for the event a great thank you to my Dr
Hefner and will for taking our time
thank you and have a great day ahead
everyone
thank you thank you very much everyone